hey what's up Radio Disney we are here
with the Janet Jackson how are you
feeling today
well artist would you love to
collaborate with now Bruno and I for a
while actually we've talked about doing
something together so we'll see I know
there's this rumor going around that we
we have we have it but every time we see
each other we still talk about doing we
both want to do something together so
it's it's really a matter of finding the
time to get together and create
something something that we both feel is
a part of us um what is your favorite
Disney show or movie my favorite Disney
movie I have to say it's it's actually
that what I just watched with my son on
the flight here and we didn't have the
heads headphones on or anything and he
was cracking up the entire time and
that's what really made it my favorite
to be able to share that moment with him
The Incredibles he was laughing in in my
lap the whole flight watching it how
does it feel to receive the first ever
Radio Disney Music Awards impact award
it's special for me on so many different
levels say my son Issa he loves Disney
he's he's a year in seven months
it's Disney's very special for me and
just to have an award named after you
and and to know that Disney is embracing
what you do and what you've done and
what it means for others coming up
behind me and and for the the Disney
viewers its and listeners it's it's it's
just a very special the impact to have
on on young people that means a lot to
me and especially coming from Disney
you
[Music]